chairman thank you
good evening and welcome to this special
strategy resources committee meeting
on tuesday the 24th of november 2020
my name is councillor richard siddall
and i am the chairman of the committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect
on the 4th of april in response to the
coveted 19 situation
and there are just a few heist keeping
issues to run through
first of all police could ask everyone
present in this meeting
to ensure your microphones remain muted
and your video feed off when you're not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is built being held
remotely
streamed live and recorded and by being
present in the meeting
you are giving your consent to be
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you
at the appropriate time members are
reminded that apart from indicating you
wish to speak
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function
should not be used for questions of
any other purpose please do not use the
raise hand function
as this is not available on all members
devices
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please
ensure you reference a page number or
paragraph
and lastly if members need to leave the
meeting at any point
please do make this known and use the
chat function
to signify that you need to leave the
meeting
now if i ask officers taking part in the
meeting
to introduce themselves starting with mr
leslie
good evening chris leslie director of
resources
thank you mr leslie mr dodson
good evening members paul dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance
thank you mr tudson mr holmes
good evening chairman bridget holmes
director of service delivery
thank you mr holmes mr holly
good evening cheering chairman even i'm
grant holly i'm
lead ict specialist thank you mr holly
mr lee
chairman oh thank you chairman sorry the
clip one click i'm matt matt lee lead
specialist place and chief plan officer
at warren district council
thank you mr lee mr halsen
uh good evening chairman i'm tim house
and i'm the council's
conservation and heritage specialist
thank you mr house and mrs
longman good evening chairman um i'm
jackie longman
the strategy theme lead for place
thank you mr salomon mr butcher
good evening chair i'm steven butcher
commercial manager
and miss holmes or miss holmes
good evening chair i'm emma holmes i'm
the lead specialist
legal and miss bird
good evening chairman good evening
members tara bird community services
officer thank you
are there any other officers at the
present that i've missed
miss bird
chairman i believe we've got um matthew
winslow with us tonight
oh okay i saw him drawing mr wimslow
yeah hello chairman uh my name is matt
winslow i am the strategy policy and
communications manager
thank you mr wimsley tara please can you
carry out a roll call of
members to confirm who is in attendance
thank you
thank you members if you just indicate
when i call your name please starting
with council mrs channel please
um hello just that's better isn't it
probably
yeah good evening miss bird good evening
officers good evening members thank you
councillor durham
thank you ms berg um i'm present and
correct leading chairman evening members
evening officers thank you
thank you that's the edwards you're
using your
presence cancer helm
present tara thank you very much
councillor lagan
yeah very good evening everybody i'm
present tara
castle schemes please
i don't think he's here chairman okay
good evening chairman good evening
members and officers i'm present
thank you councillor swain yes
good evening here that's mrs thompson
good evening everyone yes i'm present
thank you
council miss white
um miss bird um chairman
miss white's work so i think she might
be on her way like the other evening
could be late but if not then can
apologies be given
of course thank you very much and and
then members could i ask any other
members in attendance please to uh just
introduce themselves thank you
uh good evening tara councillor carly
mays thank you very much
good evening everybody
thank you that's morris thank you
chairman that finishes the roll call
thank you very much so we now come to
agenda item number two which
is apologies for absence and as far as i
understand we have no formal of
apologies is that correct
that's correct chairman yes okay thank
you very much
uh so item number three on the agenda is
to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disposable pecuniary interests
other peculiar interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph six to
eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the needs arise throughout the
meeting if any member has an interest to
declare
please choose the chat function now to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
and we have councillor durham
thank you chairman chairman i have a
non-pecuniary interest as a member of
essex county council because there are
various items pertaining to
uh that authority i also have an other
pecuniary interest
in relation to um item
uh where are we um
in relation to the item regarding wooden
walter
and the heritage assets excuse me
my parents own one of the properties but
there's no pecuniary element so
um i will uh i will remain for that part
of the meeting thank you
thank you council durham and councillor
chana
thank you chairman um same as cat well
not exactly the same as counselor down
because nothing to do with my parents
having a
property um non-pecuniary i'm also a
member of essex county council
and essex county council is referred to
actually in a fair number
of reports on many reports might have a
connection with essex county council but
i can't see any pecuniary involvement
sharon thank you thank you thank you
councillor
councillor stamp
thank you chairman um cancer schemes has
just said that he will try to join later
uh something's happened and he
apologizes but he will log on as soon as
he can chairman
thank you thank you council can you know
that uh miss bird
yes of course german noted thank you
thank you very much tara
is there anybody else who's uh declared
an interest
and no chairman no one's wishing to
speak thank you
thank you tara uh so item number four on
the agenda is public participation
participation
i can advise that we have not received
any submission from members of the
public
so we now move to agenda item number
five
which is it policies found on pages 5-16
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item
please make this known by using the chat
function within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
mr hulley please present the report
thank you chairman um so following the
strategy and resources committee meeting
from i believe just over a month ago now
uh we've succeeded in adding in
additional statements
for the acceptable use policy and
information
security policy pertaining to members
essentially this boils down to two
paragraphs um
in the information security policy there
is the addition of
a member's area for roles and
responsibilities
which correlates to that of employees
attention
essentially it's conducting their
business in
accordance with this policy and taking
responsibility
for formalizing themselves with this
policy and understand the obligations in
places on it
or in place on it and then
under acceptable use policy there is now
an additional paragraph
which has been added with input from
myself as
lead ict specialist as well as emma
holmes and simon quelch
as legal advice um essentially it
explains that under um
the systems from all district council if
monitoring is required
for example a member or staff member for
that matter
would be made aware um and that's within
a given month of that monitoring
and its requirements again this is
outside of the assumption that
the police may make a request as well or
something of a legal nature
but yes the additions have been made as
per the previous uh strategy and
resources committee meeting
and hopefully we're here to now get this
approved and and put into policy
okay thank you thank you so the
recommendation as set out
in the report is as follows that the
policies appended is one to three
we set out the security requirements
that all staff
and members must adhere to when using
mold and its systems
to ensure data security and appropriate
use
be reviewed and agreed this will also
address the required audit
recommendation
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
second thank you councillor
thank you councillor swain i will now
invite members to make any
comments on the report and i think i
have
councillor lagan
thank you chair i just want to get the
relevant page up so just excuse me for
one second
um mr haley mentioned that uh the
monitoring
um paragraph which is on page eight
of the document um we talked about the
right to examine the system
and the device in the course of business
to inspect any data
um it doesn't really say that it was in
the set period of time for there is a
set period of time for that
that monitoring to be made available
and it's probably me not reading it and
undertaking it in the way that it is
but it doesn't actually say that there
will be
a notification made to the individual
member or person being
monitored and that concerns me in a
certain respect
for um on page 12 of the the document
where it mentions about the human rights
um that that it mentions that because
you have the
the human rights uh within that and then
we'll just grab this here for you
he even writes out 1998 for articulate
um it talks about you know the digital
correspondence cell work digital
individuals the rights of privacy such
as communication
is monitoring for certain types of
things
are we 100 percent uh aligned and
convinced that monitoring would only be
undertaken if any any uh
information that was sent fell into that
criteria where it was of a legal nature
or as it says down here national
security and
because it just sits a little bit
uncomfortably to me that we can monitor
without letting people know
and they're under the human rights act
we can say no to monitoring
so they're the only things in the whole
document that that's
a bit confusing to me um so i think we
just have that confirmation that they
would be the only reasons that i'd be
happy to support
mr holly thank you chairman
um for this particular one and
considering that it's of illegal nature
i may have to hand over to emma holmes
if that's okay
that she will cover the legal side in
this regard thank you
emma do you have any information
yeah certainly um in relation to
accessing emails um there would be
if a request was made there would be a
balancing act which i think is what that
section is talking about
in terms of a member's right to privacy
um against
the the public uh interest in accessing
that information
so it's often easier with these to give
examples than try to make a general
statement
but for example if there was a criminal
investigation
of a serious nature um your right to
privacy would be overridden by the
the need for that prosecution and to
look at that
and if a request was made and i'd have
to say i don't think we've had any
any knowledge of any even requests um
that would be looked at on a
case-by-case basis
so in the majority of cases there would
have to be
uh that legal threshold of it would your
right to privacy would have to be
overridden by the need
to see that information and we'd look at
that on a case-by-case basis
okay council like are you happy with the
answer
i am i just just wondered if a
supplementary through you chair whether
that could have explicitly added into
the policy so it's really clear
in on page eight that that's what it
says
because it's not implicit in that in
that statement that is on page
about monitoring and it doesn't really
refer to page 12.
i don't have a problem being monitored
for that type of reason
at all i think is a very strong very
right thing to do but just for
for ease of use and clarity i think um i
would prefer that
but that's just a a question to put out
there for other members if
they agree then we agree with that if we
don't then we'll go with it
um i'd like to see that thank you very
much
okay thank you councillor stamp
um yes thank you chairman i agree with
councillor lagan
i also highlighted that paragraph um
i did note that mr hulley said it was to
include the members now
i believe this was debated some time ago
and members raised some very very
legitimate concerns i'm sure they have
been addressed
but i also too would like to uh if
council langan wants to propose that
amendment
i will back i will support that
amendment
i know i have been told chairman it's
pretty standard policy everywhere
uh that that may well be uh but i
totally agree with what uh miss emma
holmes has said but i would like it in
writing that they
are the reasons and the exclusions or
inclusions for it chairman
i'm not happy with the way it is worded
there and if we could agree to that i
think that would be fantastic
um also chairman i do notice about
social media etc etc and i've just made
a couple of comments really chairman
social media isn't always negative
social media can be positive
so we do have to be careful we're not
going to be too prescriptive and nailing
everything
down i understand where the report is
possibly coming from but i'm also a
great
believer as long as it isn't actually
what's the word
causing any distress or legal
implications
for what's been posted i totally support
it
but i don't want us to be too
prescriptive that we do stop
the element of debate and what we can
actually put on social media
as i've said it can be used in a
positive way and i think many members of
this council
have used it in a positive way i
certainly have and promote malden
district council
as i did burnham town council um so
they're my comments thank you i don't
think there needs to be a response
chairman
unless other members do wish to support
our recommended amendment or not
thank you chair thank you council stamp
counselor channel
um yes thank you chairman uh
firstly can i just take the liberty of
this um councillor whites
um text me and emailed me she's having
trouble getting in
um there's some problem with her lines
and she's trying the mobile wi-fi is not
working on the ipad and she doesn't have
a wi-fi tonight
because someone sent her a telephone
number to to ring in on is that possible
chair and i'm sorry about that but
i've just got the message come up so i
said i'd ask when
um i was going to speak on this item can
i just say the points council legends
raid actually
um and i'm sort of larger as well i
guess councillor stamp
actually i think when it did come up at
the last committee meeting i'm pretty
sure that i myself did make reference to
the fact that if anyone was looking at
my
my emails um for whatever reason then
i'd like to be informed and i've got a
feeling that was stated and i'm not so
sure
that it wasn't sort of minuted to that
effect not necessarily
declaring my name but i certainly did
say that i'd want to know
and also i'm not sure that what it does
cover bearing in mind i'm a data
controller as we all are and i
appreciate the council is
if my emails are monitored at any one
time the reason i would like to know is
because obviously i have a lot of
confidential information
from residents on there or residents
coming to me personally and i don't
distribute necessarily all those emails
and hence therefore i'm not quite clear
and perhaps it does can the officer
confirm that the the um
sort of passing on information does
cover that aspect where someone in it
and it's nothing personal against ids i
don't think that
i'm just trying to get this clear in my
head that if someone of mighty is
monitoring my
emails and they see stuff of
confidential nature
giving names addresses of residents that
that's not passed on
either and it's forgotten so just like
that qualified chairman
and there was one particular point where
and i'm sorry perhaps i missed it i have
read this document twice and i'm not
sure
quite sure of this paragraph that covers
the members because what i
did pick up um on a particular page
i'm just going to get it was appendix 2
page 5 of the document
i think page 13 on the order paper and
it is about actually
um abusive um of sort of emails we might
receive from wherever
not necessarily no public could be
elsewhere
and it says that tell your line manager
i'm not sure that actually um relates to
members so
i just like some clarity on that because
you know we may receive
abusive emails or making statements we
consider offensive
abusive and if that's the case um
we don't have line managers as such
what's our best reporting route is it
the monitoring officer
um our group leaders um or
directors because i think obviously
members can receive such things we might
see emails where it's widely spread
or whatever and i think we need to be
protected when we are receiving
um all these um abusive emails if we did
you know i appreciate sometimes
residents get frustrated and write stuff
but
um you know just like to know about that
because that seems to refer to
officers only and managers being advised
okay thank you
mrs holmes or mr holly would you like to
answer those questions
thank you chairman i'll come in for some
of this um so
just whilst emma's looking at the
document as well she's she's just
working out some wording for us
um just to cover or sort of go through
the control mechanism here
um essentially when a data request is
made
um that request has to be formalized and
formally delivered to
for example myself or one of my team as
i t
from a director of modern district
council
when that request is made the
information that is gathered
isn't necessarily read by an ict
specialist
it would be collated and put into a
document for the eyes of that requesting
director only
the director then has control over what
happens to that information
that information for example might need
to go to the police if it's that type of
request
or it may be that the director views
that information and says actually
there's nothing to worry about
and shuts the case down it's it's a
controlled method of access it isn't
just
jump in and look for the sake of it we
need very specific
requests and controls in place to make
sure a request can take place
for any data access which director would
it go to mr holly
again it can be any one of the three
directors that's for redundancy to make
sure that
someone can cater to the next different
and that would relate to
members if a member had something around
that cancer
channel was talking about one that would
look at that
so so we have an additional document
here um so this was
um i just put it up as well um members
use of it systems this was again written
by in the homes
and very kindly i believe circulated i
hope it has been
um this goes into further detail um
but essentially as i say it's controlled
access it
we can't for example receive a even a
freedom of information request um
without first going through a director
to to allow for that information to be
passed out or it you know given out to
anywhere else
so yes thank you mr holly mrs holmes are
you ready to come back or shall i go to
councillor stan
now i can um i've hearing a couple of
comments
in terms of the the wording um
i i think we can probably add uh
a sentence onto the the the policy
in relation to the human rights act the
that section that says about monitoring
individuals
um i'm thinking something as simple as
emails will only
be accessed where this legal
justification can be met
so if if if i take you it's page
12 and it's got the heading human rights
act
and then you've got a paragraph that
says however monitoring individuals
email and digital correspondence at work
may be justified if
it was in accordance with the law so i'm
suggesting
somewhere at the at the end of that
paragraph to add the line emails will
only be accessed where this
where this legal justification can be
met and hopefully
if that if that would assist members in
hopefully
easing uh their fears and their concerns
here
okay uh do i have a
i don't think we need to amend the
recommendation for that to happen
um as mr holmes is saying that she's
prepared to make that
amendment our members uh satisfied
that we can move on to the vote
i'd like to just come back chairman and
just say that uh councillor
durham very kindly helped me because i
couldn't think of my word i've had
meetings since
nine o'clock this morning so i do
apologize and i thank cancer durham
the word i was looking for was
defamatory so obviously if it's
something illegal defamatory
exactly or can cause somebody great
heartache or whatever
defamatory is a very good word so that's
what i
meant to say i totally agree with the
recommendation now
um thank you cancer sydney okay
uh so in terms of the the
vote um are we prepared to take a cent
for this or do we need a recorded vote
council lagging you want a secondary
yeah sorry it's not security i'll just
say um
emma thanks for that that's exactly what
i want but can we also add into that
that members will be informed
at this stage of the initial inquiry so
or the email user will be used
informed uh immediately at the stage of
the initial inquiry because then
everything is transparent then
take a chair okay ms lambert are you
happy with that
i have a slight concern with that only
thinking in hypothetical situations is
that if the police asked us
to make and gave us a formal recommend a
formal request to access information
and it was in relation to a serious
crime they may ask us
not to pass that information on so
putting that
statement in there i would be slightly
uncomfortable
we could add something along in most
circumstances
something like that to cover us for
those situations
um if if that that would be that would
probably ease my fears because there may
be and i think it would be very rare i'm
not aware of it
but i wouldn't want to tie us in so i
could certainly add something
um um unless in exceptional
circumstances
the email user will be notified
within the calendar month or something
along those lines so yeah we can
certainly add that
thank you mrs holmes uh council channel
is this a new question
yes chairman it is okay um
chairman regarding the recommendation
and for this committee to agree could i
just say that under the terms of
reference of the committee
actually as this is a policy um document
which i think has got corporate
significance
should this perhaps be a recommendation
to council and not one that this
committee can agree
um and i'm i'm referring to the the
terms of reference of the committee
chairman so i just make that inquiry i
think
is this not a document bearing in his
mind it is a policy document covering
officers and members of this authority
that it should actually therefore go to
council for agreement and that should be
a recommendation
not a resolve of the committee thank you
uh mrs holmes
you should be able to answer that
question for me
or mr dodson
i'm just pulling next yeah
happy too that that is correct that
should be
that it's a recommendation to to counsel
i would i would understand all right
thank you mr dutton
uh so uh in terms of this recommendation
we are now
uh agreeing the recommendation that we
put forward the recommendation for the
policy to
full council to to agree that
uh can we do that via send or do we need
a recorded vote
a great thank you very much
chairman sorry just to confirm subject
to those amendments yes
yes correct thank you very much
so uh we now move on to agenda item
number six
which is planning enforcement found on
pages 17 to 74.
members are reminded that if you wish to
speak on this item
please make this known by using the chat
function within this meeting i will then
come to you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succinct mr lee
please present the report
thank you chairman um
members will be aware from the report
that in july
at full council councillor heard raised
a query in relation
to planning enforcement and outstanding
investigations and it was agreed that
the leader at the time counts heard
along with the
chairs of the various planning
committees would meet
with officers to discuss this matter at
this meeting it was agreed that a number
of
points would be looked into in relation
to trying to reduce the backlog
and expediate the enforcement process
one of the key ones
is the production of a new planning
enforcement policy
um as members will be aware
it's not exp sorry it's not
it let me start again as members aware
it is discretionary for the council to
undertake enforcement action but that is
materially different
to it being discretionary for the
council to undertake
a thorough and appropriate investigation
of the leaded breach of planning control
and that's a slight technicality which
sometimes is
overlooked in the wording but as
explained enough to report
one of the ways to come to a correct
robust decision on the expediency of
taking
enforcement is to have an up-to-date
policy
so officers have reviewed the policy
that was attached to
pending one which is the existing policy
and considered
ways of improving it streamlining it and
looking to
expedite the process particularly in
relation to
people trying to slow the process down
through negotiation or
looking to submit planning applications
when it's a development of the council
thinks it's unlikely to support and that
conditions wouldn't overcome harm
with that in mind appendix 2 attaches to
proposed policy as members we have to
see
it hasn't been done with track changes
or anything like that which is normally
the way we look to do
things like that in planning when we've
done amendments policy because it is
such substantially different that
wouldn't have worked
but section 3.3 provides
a list of the headlines of the major
changes
unknown participant is now joining can
answer swain could you please turn your
mic off
thank you and um someone else is just
but yeah as i said that's a section
sorry for german the section 3.3 covers
all the
main changes and obviously
recommend that the policy is recommended
to full council for adoption thank you
chairman
thank you mr lee so the recommendations
are set out in the report are as follows
that the planning enforcement policy
appendix 2
is recommended for adoption 2 full
council
little 2 that members note the inclusion
within the 2021-22
budget cycle growth request the
provision of additional staffing
resources if any member wishes to second
that emotion
please turn on your video and mute your
microphone
and state your name now councillor lagan
seconded thank you councillor logan
thank you i now invite members to make
any comments on the on the report
and uh i think we have
cancer channel is that right miss bird
yes tamara that's right okay
um thank you very much chairman um
mr lee actually referred to an area
where it defines really where the
the issues are and it is um chairman i
think it's from page 19
3.3.3 and it says about
setting new performance targets
um and in the in the document i was just
wondering should that be something
that the committee performance
governance and audit should consider
as well bearing in mind they are
involved in the performance of service
delivery and
enforcement is very much that case also
chairman regarding the appendix um
page 33 there's a flow chart which shows
the flow
of um what happens in cases
and it seems to end on planning
contraventions
um what i was a bit concerned with um
chairman and it was a 7.2 on page 37 i
think
it said regarding policies agreed and
action approved under powers delegated
directors
of of planning resources mr dodson
that'll be
or through relevant committee
councillors involvement according to
council's constitution at times um i'm
just a bit concerned by that because
we used to have a policy it was quite
clear and i couldn't see anywhere within
this appendix
um where by ward members before an
enforcement notice
um was issued they would receive it and
have been asked for
comments on it i can't remember the last
time i got one in my ward
and i'm a bit concerned bearing in mind
the flow chart ends on page 33 just to
do with the planning contravention
notice
and then i was hoping to find another
flow chart where it showed you the other
stages which went on
which is including the enforcement
notice um
sort of being served um so i felt there
was a bit of incompleteness there
chairman if i'm honest
but i would like this matter of ward
members because we were very much
involved
and also bearing in mind something else
it referred to
about committees relevant committees
well we've recently agreed that
enforcement reports won't go to
committees and i think that might just
be the month long ones
so can i have some clarification on that
are we saying
if appropriate then a committee will
receive report on an enforcement notice
being served
because 7.2 paragraphs as i've just said
on page 37
doesn't really imply that to me but i'm
very concerned about members
and what i'd like to know actually is
i've got um i think it might have been
useful or perhaps we could have it or it
might be pga
i'd like to know very much within my
ward to the number of enforcement
notices that have been served
because i can't remember really the last
time that i was ever asked to give a
view on one
and i'm sorry that's a complex question
sharon but that all actually
actually all areas do have synergies
with each other that's why i've
encompassed it in just
one sentence mr lee did you get
the questions from council of china
i'll do my best as always chairman if
i've missed anything i'm sure councillor
channel can flag it up to me
um i think there's this
well first i think one of the things
that maybe i didn't explain i'm not
sure if the report really goes into one
of the decisions to
undertake is that the old policy
it wasn't just a policy also included
our internal process our practice
guidance etc
and that made it quite excessive it was
a big document that
wasn't to the point and so one of the
things is that
that's it could you please
mute appendix 2 which is the new policy
only is about the policy so things such
as internal processes and practices
are silent on this document because that
that is a different approach and
obviously the point that council channel
was saying about this flowchart and
obviously you know making reference to
presentation
committees or you know old job titles
that's because that's actually in
relation to the old policy the one
that's currently in situ
rather than the one that we're proposing
that members recommend for adoption
to my knowledge um members are still
being consulted before we take
enforcement action um i know
recently i think um we served a
stop notice and the board members were
informed of that um
but i can't off the cuff comment on any
particular case on
um that has or hasn't been but if i'm
happy to get officers to confirm to
councillor channel if there have been
any enforcement notices served in her
wallet within the last six months
and if um i can't actually comment on
specifics
of course um i hope that's answered the
questions
because it's a big issue yeah sorry just
the cloud the big issue is that
counselor channels asking questions
about the old policy rather than new
policy
council challenges you wanted to come
back yes please chairman for me
and i don't want to sort of drag this
out too much but
i'm sorry i'm a bit confused because
that might be the old policy
that you say i'm referring to but 7.2
page 37 says policies agreed an action
approved
under powers delegated to director of
planning
resources etc or whatever the title of
mr dawson is
or through relevant committees
councillors involvement according to
council constitution
at the time so i was expecting to see
clearly defined in the policy about
members
would be consulted and on foot before
the serving of enforcement notice
i'm if it's in the old policy then okay
why hasn't that been carried over into
this new one because i think we should
and actually it is probably for pga to
actually have a whole list of all
members wards where enforcement notices
have been served
and see the numbers that did get um
sort of passed on to members before they
were actually served i'm not saying they
might not have been there might not be
that many
but i don't think this policy covers
that aspect i've highlighted chairman
so i'm just keen to make sure that this
policy doesn't remove
the requirement for members to be
consulted before the serving of an
enforcement notice
mr lee does that ever been the case
because i don't remember that in the
time that i've been a councillor
thank you chairman um i said paragraph
that counselor channel is referring to
it's in the sec is an existing policy
and as that does that ties that into our
the constitution which is obviously
separate to the policy that overrides or
overrides it they sit side by side
so the requirements of that will be done
that is a
slightly separate matter to what our
enforcement policy is um
it's a bit like you don't have our
schema delegation in the local plan
then they're separate matters so and
this is just literally looking at like a
local plan for planning enforcement
and then the scheme of delegation is our
constitution but
to my knowledge we are consulting um
board members before serving enforcement
though so
you know as members are aware we
discussed this obviously there will be
new members of the committee we
discussed this last time at full council
when enforcement came up as the query
and there obviously had to be a
hiatus one of a better phrase during the
uh pandemic and lockdown because
we wouldn't been able to serve it in
fulton's notes because they won't
actually be now to comply with it
because they wouldn't be able to get
builders in and all the rest of it so
there would have been a there has been a
legacy where we haven't really
i know been able to be that proactive
but i'm happy to
get an update for members if if the
committee wishes that
okay thank you mr lee uh
counselor stan uh thank you chairman
um just for the benefit of all the
members of public who'll be
watching at the moment can i ask mr lee
if he would
just if i give him an example to say
what category of urgent
or non-urgent enforcement would come
under and i'm glad he's actually just
used the term a temporary stop notice
was issued
because this is what i think members of
the public and the perception of
enforcement
when it directly affects them want to
know what malden district council are
going to do for them
and i'll use an example of something
that happened recently in burnham
and that i don't think it will
actually it was all over social media
and please jump in on mr lee to stop me
if i'm going to get myself would you say
that there are
if it's not if it's an enforcement
ongoing enforcement case council stamp i
won't be able to
comment because it will be confidential
can i give you an example
rather than a particular one so say for
example
generic thank you obvious a lot of help
tonight so i appreciate that so say for
example
you're sitting in your garden and you've
been having
constant noise from a development site
near you and it's been going on from 6
a.m till 10
p.m and you've seen something which has
concerned you
either outside working their hours they
should be
what category of enforcement does that
go into
is it a 15 day a 25 day
is it what because i know for a fact and
i think other members
may back me up on this that is what we
get a lot of complaints about
um is that fair mr lee does that come
under enforcement as you said temporary
stop notice and i
think that's what that would come under
thank you
well i think there's two different
things there one is that
is whether or not the breach would be
classed as
what category and i don't think most
instances that would fall within the
urgent
class rather than the higher one which
is obviously immediate which
literally relates to things where it's
going to be a lost asset such as a list
of building or a tree or if there is
you know real risk to life or health um
the second point about whether or not it
won't a
temporary stop notices is very hard to
comment on it needs to be assessed
on the expediency and what government
guidance
is and temporary stop notices are quite
draconian
tall and we shouldn't be using them
lightly and there is
a financial risk that accounts if we do
use them so i can't really comment on
that per se
um but you know the example council stan
would use i would assume would fall
within
the urgent case which would be 15 days
for first sight visit
but i think that's part of what this
policy is to do is to
i think it's not if i'm honest it's not
the class that they fall within which is
the thing that
the members of public are maybe raising
concerns with it's how long it takes
from
raising that complaint to it being
resolved and the point is that this
policy
firstly looks to expedite the process
but it does also bring in
a target which we've never had before in
relation to cases being
when you use the word dealt with but
then that's up to the point where we're
going to serve an enforcement notice or
the point where an application has been
approved it doesn't mean the breach will
have ceased because
if we service a enforcement notice
there'll be a compliance period
they always appeal so that'll then take
could take a year
so it's not it's there's now a target
for us to deal with cases in
the period that we can control so um and
that's something that hasn't existed
before so i think you know this is quite
a it's a
it's a very big change what we've had
before it's not as friendly as in it is
much more
moving cases forward but and obviously
there is an impact on the person that's
breaching the control
in respect of that but i think it has a
much
there is much more of an impact and a
better impact on the people that are
subject
and are being impacted upon by the
breach of planning control so
hopefully members will understand that
and support the policy change thank you
chairman
yeah thank you chairman thank you mr lee
i think that's really important you
passed a lot of information over to
members of public who are watching that
watching this meeting as i'm sure they
all are
and i actually thank you for explaining
it thank you chair thank you
councillor swain
yes thank you chairman um first of all
if i can
um refer to the um the
points that counselor channel was making
um
yes as i understand it detailed and
information
on enforcements won't go to
area planning committees um but they
would be
posted uh somewhere else for as a point
of reference
but in this case um uh
i think there should be some a regular
reporting
and i would uh like to see a
quarterly report which probably would go
to pgna
um in a broad sense covering the
categories of complaint
and um with details of what the
council's responses have been
um on issues on
issues of currently under review
um that i would
like to put as an additional
recommendation
um i would also like to make
a general observation
and we're told that we must
investigate where there's an enforcement
complaint
but we don't have to go into
enforcement we're told that
we can act if it's considered expedient
and then 3.2.6 it says in most cases
it's not illegal to
breach planning controls um there's
no obligation for people to cooperate
and there's a large discretionary area
here
um and this seems to me
i'm quite a bit uneasy about the whole
situation
either either under
the regulations the planning officers
have us almost crazy judicial role
or we're saying that the final arbiters
on whether something is an important
matter of planning lies with the
magistrates and the courts
um i'm not sure about the lawfulness of
the whole system
mr lee can you answer any of those
questions for councillor swain
i can i can do my best chairman for you
chairman um
i don't think i comment on the
lawfulness of the whole planning system
it's been going a while so
no one's challenged its fundamental
awfulness i think that's pretty secure
um i think there's i think
obviously the document is written with
a certain assumption of levels of
knowledge so i might need to roll back
and just explain a little bit
more when in most instances take
breaching a planning control is not
illegal
um the idea is that it's a member of
public
they're unaware of the planning system
they've maybe stumbled or it's
minor etc that's sort of the
understanding of why it's not illegal
that differ with adverts because it's a
commercial
enterprise that's undertaken that but
also with things such as listed building
and trees because there's a very fine
limited asset
and if they were to be destroyed or lost
there's a much
immediate harm but otherwise pretty much
all of planning control is not illegal
until the council serves the notice so
it could be an enforcement note to
temporary stop notice breach condition
notice
and once they've bitten once they're in
place undertaking works on
so if it was a breach condition notice
it said you
only can open within your opening hours
and then you open later than that
that's illegal if we served a
enforcement note said you've got to
knock down your extension within six
months
and you don't that becomes illegal so
that is separate to whether or not you
know the expedience of taking action
expediency taking action is is there
harm so if somebody could build a three
meter extension
they're on a their house that needed
plan information there's no neighbors
around and they build it at 3.2 meters
you may think actually we would grant
this plan information we put no
conditions on it
so there is no benefit for one of a bit
word for anybody to actually take action
why make them remove it from 0.2 of a
meter when you know it's not hurting
anyone for a better phrase
and that's basically the expediency test
is there harm or not
if there is harm then the council does
take action
um you know we've publicized recently
that brief
condition notice where we prosecuted a
gentleman you know members were aware of
that
you know a few years ago we actually
made somebody demolish the whole
bungalow because they built it without
permission
we do take action when it is considered
expediency so i hope members
one of the reasons we have a backlog is
because we don't just
you know fairly flippantly decide
they're not experiencing take action and
close the cases so
i hope actually that backlog supports
members understanding that we're not
trying to just
ignore breaches of planning control and
not take action
but as i said that is separate to the
magistrates point which is only
when there has been an illegal activity
so there's a number of that
and that's where the time spent is
officers negotiating and trying to
resolve
the breach then we'll serve a notice and
then they'll appeal that
so that's normally a couple of years
happens of work before you end up in
court actually
so hopefully that sucks that sort of
answer counts as wayne's question
thank you chairman thank you mr lee
cancer
uh yes i won't pursue the uh the law for
this aspect
perhaps i couldn't come back with a
recommendation because i think some sort
of
reporting on the state of uh enforcement
uh and what progress is being made and
particularly
how what kind how many are treated
in those different categories of urgent
or not so urgent or whatever
um that are under review and that a
regular report in fairly general terms
should be made so that you can keep
track of the performance of the
enforcement team
okay mr lee could that be put into the
document
uh an amendment to the document rather
than an amendment to the recommendations
uh that that that i'm not sure i don't
think it would be for the document
because it is a policy rather than right
i
think that may be something i might need
to remember i don't know if mr dodson or
mrs holmes can answer that better i'm
not that's slightly out of my
comfort zone but yeah thank you okay
mr holmes and mr dodson do we need to
put an additional recommendation
that a report is sent to a
one of the committees at a set period
would that be an additional
recommendation
thank you chairman yes that that's fine
yes
thank you chairman yes we're happy we
can accommodate that uh okay so we'll
we'll come
we'll add that as an additional
recommendation um when we get to the to
that part of the
of the this item on the agenda uh i have
seen the notes about councillor white i
am taking people
in order and the next person in terms of
wanting to speak was councillor lagan
thank you chair i'll just be quite brief
um i've learned
in my time as a member that planning is
rather complex and i'm pleased we've got
such proficient officers
um as as matt said it's a policy
document
and as a policy document you can't get
down in the weeds with it
so i think that what counselor channel
actually said has has great validity
maybe maybe adding in somewhere that's
explicitly says that in in
circumstances of notices being issued
the world members which unified
you've clarified this as well you know
the these sort of appeals and processes
are long
they're expensive they're emotionally
draining so um
i think the policy is in itself is is
pretty strong
and i appreciate that the development of
it so i just wanted to note that thank
you
okay thank you council lane i apologize
councillor dumb i will now come to you
next
that's all right thank you chairman
chairman of the chat
sorry yeah no that's all right
um chairman i i think just to just a
point of information i mean we're
the reason that originally we one of the
reasons
uh that we wanted the officers to to
alert us to
uh enforcement or potential enforcement
was not because we were precious about
wanting to know everything happening in
our
awards but there are occasions where we
might have other information that might
um you know provide the officers
with an answer which may save everybody
a whole lot of time
and and grief um so yeah it's
it's not not that we were being um you
know dictatorial and wanting to know
absolutely everything uh and of course
in many cases that's actually the member
ourselves uh that are lodging the
enforcement
um uh identifying the
the issues uh that may or may not lead
to to enforcement
um i i can safely say that sometimes we
are
alerted sometimes we're not uh mr lee
uh yes um he did alert me to a temporary
stop notice that he issued
um and uh which was very very very
welcome by myself and the and the parish
council
um but that actually was probably a
result of me plaguing his life for about
um a fortnight and and the officers the
other thing i'd like to raise which is
it gives members some difficulties
particularly when at parish councils
when we get
um because enforcement is let's say one
of the things that parish councils get
very excited about
um and we get the uh
the reports which are of course
watermark confidential
and it sometimes puts members in a
difficult position
where we know through reading our
reports
about the state of uh an enforcement
case
but because it's watermark confidential
we're not actually allowed to tell
the parish council and i you know i
haven't got an answer to that but i just
wanted to float that out and see what
you or the officers thought about it
thank you thank you
mr lee
chairman um thank you chairman said
before that mike came on
um i think it's an interesting point um
if i'm honest
the previous authorities i've worked at
members haven't had a report like that
about enforcement
so that was a mute point there they um
there was no information before members
to actually discuss um
but you know i think it is appropriate
that the cases are
confidential there is obviously
potential that if
information was to get into the wider
public it could prejudice our ability to
take action but also i think you've got
to remember that a lot of the cases we
find there aren't breaches of planning
control as well
and i think for those individuals we
need to protect
them and to ensure that they aren't
you know unfairly marked especially
sometimes
investigations can take a while but i do
understand members frustrations but
i know it's something we've looked at
before and it's always had back that it
does need to remain confidential
thank you chairman okay thank you
chairman and i totally agree that they
should remain confidential thank you
thank you mr lee
thank you council councillor white
apparently if you press six counts away
you'll come off mute
from what i understand
which is bear with star six apparently
if you try that cancel away
doesn't seem to be working for her
uh cancer thompson well hopefully uh
what i'll as you ask the question
councillor white will be able to come
off mute
thank you yes some perhaps if i can slot
in while we wait to cancel a white
um i'm looking and looking it might be
in the document and i apologize if it is
and i've missed it and it's probably a
question
through you for mr lee but
my parish council certainly believes
they should be given updates on
enforcement
um it certainly was written in the
policy at some point
but the difficulty is it's confidential
and i agree that's
as it should be so i don't know quite
what they could be that we could update
them with but
um yeah there's one one
parish council in particular most of the
councils of
different people now would say well why
aren't we getting a report
well could mr lee enlighten us through
you please
mr lee thank you chairman um
we do update parishes when they
are the people that have raised the
complaint
just like we do anybody else who has
raised a complaint um
i do know some parishes feel that they
should be
kept in the loop one of the better
phrases of every complaint in their
parish but once again it's confidential
and sexually that would be a lot of
officer time potentially to deal with
matters because we'd have to actually
provide them with an update even what
the breach was in most in
some instances where they're not even
aware of it i think the bigger issue is
actually
it's not that and this isn't just for
parishes it's generally for complaints
it's actually the time that's taken for
the investigation so the time between
being able to make a reasonable and
update of any value
is quite extensive and that's one of the
problems where people are playing the
planning system for one of a better
phrase where they're
manipulating and slowing it down so
we've ended up in negotiations for eight
months so we haven't told or complaining
anything because there isn't anything to
tell them
the whole point of this report is to
actually these new policies to
shrink that process so we will still be
making updates to count
to councillors if they're the people
that have raised the complaint it
parishes any whoever it is
but hopefully now this will mean that it
will
ensure that it's much quicker so people
shouldn't be complaining because they
should be getting these updates
quicker and as it says also in the
report
we've looked at bringing in some
standard templates as well
that will go out as almost standard
letters giving updates so
that should actually save officers time
as well so those
two things together should hopefully
make the perception of enforcement much
better
thank you chairman cancer thompson you
want to come back
yes please um again through you could i
just
ask um what the updates consist of is it
as each um a sort of
each stage has been reached i presume it
doesn't contain any detail
or how much detail does it contain thank
you
mr lee
um to be honest it is a little bit of
horses for food tremendously it's a
little bit horses for courses um
depending on what the breach is what the
information is
at what stage it is um so
obviously what we're looking to do is
let the complaint know when a site
visits been undertaken
and predominantly what the outcome is or
when we've got to a stage that we're
likely to
taking action or coming to a resolution
or we've got
a certain level of information um it is
like i'm hoping it should be a little
bit more
informed than previously partly because
it should be quicker
so there will be more information to be
able to get to rather
than you know sometimes we have touch
base with complainants and it's been
very little we've been able to inform
them because at the stage there is very
little to say
so by shortening the whole process
hopefully we'll be able to give much
better and quicker information
but it's not so i can give a definitive
on what it'll be in each instance
because it will
very much depend on the breach thank you
thank you mr lee that's helpful thank
you thank you councillor
hello chairman thank you very much um i
think councillor white
um says she might have sorted it now so
you might want to go back to her
so i won't i was going to raise her
point but i'll let her do that if she
can get in
chairman i'm sorry to sort of go on
about this point and i hear what mr lee
said about this being a policy document
but my point was regarding the appendix
and specifically regarding the flow
chart
the flow chart shows the process of what
happens when we get the complaints
and it ends at the planning
contravention my point is chairman
after that the process continues and we
may get down to the point of an
enforcement
notice being served it seems to me that
it's not complete i was expecting to
find part two
of the flowing process so if it's a
policy document but we can have part
one shown by a flow diagram down to the
planning contravention bit
why can't we then have the remainder of
that following
that serving of the planning
controversial note is down to the point
where
some action enforcement notice or
whatever
is taken chairman regarding the point
also of enforcement
and updates and we've agreed that those
reports won't go to main committees
i think bearing in mind there are new
chairmen of committees chairman
and it was agreed as actually the area
planning committees
um the chairman of an area planning
committee can seek to call a meeting
solely ideally in the daytime because
the more the
team will be there to hold a meeting to
talk about enforcement only that would
include
an update or members questions and then
be able to go on to specific cases
because it would be
um a private meeting chairman so i just
check those points
okay mr lee is there missing items from
the flowchart
and can a area planning
uh chairman call a meeting around
enforcement
through chairman um obviously i haven't
made myself clear previously
the flowchart that counselor channel
refers to on page 33
is what is included in appendix one
which is the current
policy document which is currently
adopted there is no flowchart in the new
document in the new policy because this
is not the polit the flowchart doesn't
relate to the policy that relates to
operational matters so
there is no flowchart in the new
document and
to certainly whether or not the
flowchart in the old document is correct
is a bit of a
you know relevance to a certain sentence
but
the the policy is detailed in the new
document in terms of how that process
works yeah and in relation to the second
point
of chance she is perfectly correct um
members agreed to
no longer have reports go to area
committees but in exchange they would
the chairman were to be
able to call um meetings to
discuss planning enforcement which would
include information so
um yeah that's two channels it's up to
the committee to make a decision but as
councillor channel said
we've sort of already got something
better than what's been proposed in the
system thank you
thank you mr lee councillor white
we can hear you ah oh he's just told me
i'm no longer muted
right um thank you thank you for letting
me into the meeting um
i apologize for um not being able to log
in but um all of my alarms on my
accounts ipad are set
via wi-fi and somebody kindly pulled all
of our telephone wires down today and in
fact i'm waiting for the bbc man to come
out um so that's why i didn't even know
there was a meeting tonight but
um right firstly i was never happy
with the enforcement being removed from
planning meetings because that was when
we actually
raised several items with officers that
actually brought
forward enforcement um issues
that had just sort of stopped did in the
water
um so i'm really concerned about that um
ostensibly i'm okay with less info in
the update
because some of it is duplicated but we
still need the updates and we still need
them
with where we are in the action but my
main concerns are that
we don't know as members what's going on
with these enforcement actions because
i've raised
several and i've had chase and chase and
chase
and whereas we used to have officers who
we could email and speak to about
enforcement
now it just goes to enforcement so we
don't actually get to know anything and
i think
without having the office we can speak
to i
would almost think it needs to go back
to the planning meetings or have one
meeting
every two months purely for enforcement
because
we have to be updated because the main
thing the parish councils
as councillor dharam and china have said
get upset about is the enforcement and i
know several i've raised and i cannot
get any information on them and it
doesn't actually say anything in the
members updates that's one
thing i would like to know where we are
on it um
the second thing is um that i wonder if
um
this should almost go to the working
group to be reviewed because i i think
it needs more detail
i can't print the agenda off tonight and
i can't view it but i did read it
um yesterday and from what i remember
the flow chart ended and it didn't
actually give
all of the information that was required
um and i'd like
an answer on that one um you know
because we
we need the information and so far
we're not getting the information um but
if somebody could mute me now that would
be fantastic
thank you council away well i i think
we've established that the flowchart
covers part
of the process and then the policy
details
the rest of the process so the the the
process is there
but it's not put in a flowchart form the
other thing we need to be clear about
is that any lists and updates in terms
of the information that's provided to
members
is for members and planning officers
only and should not be discussed at a
parish council meeting
that's because no no no no no but from
our point of view
if i might come back mr chairman and
from our point of view i never ever give
details of what's going on but i
generally say
you know any issues are being
investigated but we
now can't even find out if they actually
are because
a lot of them stall and at the old
meetings we always used to bring them up
and we'd get things reinvestigated
and you know often they'd come back and
say we'll look into this it doesn't get
looked into
and that's my concern is that's not in
the policies or i couldn't find it in
the policies
you know where we're going forward from
there because the policy is one thing
but we need to be clear on the route
that it takes and for me
that's missing and that's where i think
it needs further scrutiny because it is
very important
okay thank you council apparently if you
do star 6 yourself
you can unmute and mute yourself so just
to let you know that i've just been
advised of that information
let's try it again now i've got the
right screen up this time
okay mr lee chairman um
i think i can understand members
frustration and members wants or needs
in relation to information
from the previous reports and what was
done previously but that was something
that was agreed
relatively recently by a separate
committee that's the separate matter to
the planning enforcement
policy it's a similar matter as i said
earlier about schema like
looking at the plan applications to
schema delegation to the ldp
this is there just the ldp the points on
whether we have meetings to
uh weekly monthly don't have them at all
is a is a separate matter to this policy
and i just want to make sure that
members are
conscious that when discussed in this if
you know and i said
that was a matter that wasn't agreed
that long ago by a separate committee
and i
i can't comment on that thank you
chairman of local planning committees
can call meetings into enforcement if
they so require
and yeah and we have that yeah thank you
thank you i mean i i would just like to
raise
as an old member who's been around for a
while that this
is just for me one level of democracy
being removed and we're not being kept
updated as members we need to know
exactly what's going on okay
okay uh so early we had a recommendation
from
councillor swain council swing could you
specify that recommendation for us
please
i'm thinking yes chairman what up as a
third one i would
say that a quarterly report be made to
performance governance and audit
committee detailing the categories
of complaint and the nature of the
council's responses
okay thank you can we have a second for
that motion
i'll second that chairman councillor
stan was seconded okay
did you sorry keep it fairly vague
because they would leave it for pgna
to uh more detail if they wish
okay mr lee did you want to come back
three chairman oh
i'm my only concern is um in most
instances
within a month of uh a complaint being
received the only update would be a site
visit's been undertaken
um so i think you just had a review
report in terms of the number of my
items outstanding yeah i think it would
be very limited weight of what we'd
actually be able to
i said if it's for another committee
maybe it should be a recommendation
should be that they review it and see
what they would request rather than
us as this committee deciding what it is
they want as councillors wayne said i
don't
know suggest but i'm just conscious that
we were just only
only worth having a report if it's
actually got detail that members can
actually use that we could leave it for
pg
a to take up okay so perhaps
perhaps you can perform a a
recommendation to
pgna rather than snr to see whether they
want to put that forward as a
recommendation cancer swing
okay that would be the recommendations
that
we recommend that we have seconds so
we can have a vote on that chairman i
can withdraw my
second in and then then i think it may
fail
okay so so we can can we uh
can we talk to yeah identify what the
reasoning behind the report is and then
decide on whether some form of report
needs to go as part of an audit process
that pg a look at in terms of
enforcement
can we can we put that forward to
something that a that pg
a look at rather than having a
recommendation at this stage
because i don't think it's clear exactly
what it is would be in that report and
what the purpose of the report was
but um yes that's fair enough as long as
pg they
sort of pick up the ball and run yeah
okay i'm sure you can contact the
chairman of pgna to put that forward
to them okay thank you council this way
so the if i go back to the
recommendations so the recommendations
are that the planning enforcement policy
appendix ii is recommended for adoption
to full council
uh little two that members note the
inclusion within the 21-22 budget cycle
growth
requests the provision of additional
staffing resources
are we do we do this by ascent or would
you like a recorded vote
great thank you thank you very much
agree so
we now move on to item
item number seven i'm sorry i don't
agree with this so if you could note
that i don't agree with that at all
thank you okay so
if we don't agree with then we have to
do a recorded vote
okay are we taking both items together
can we not do both dissent chairman
descent ask for clarification from tara
can you not just have dissent
listed for councillors right yeah
chairman had we have been advised that
if not all members are agreeing
we don't have a cent then we should be
taking a vote it doesn't have to be a
recorded vote but just the fact we all
take we need to take a vote
okay so
in terms of the uh it's one person
against is that correct
yeah do you should i just could you run
through their names is that the
yes please okay so this is for both the
recommendations as you just detailed
chairman
if you could just indicate four against
your abstain please council mrs channel
four providing all the points have been
taken into account
okay thank you councillor durham
four counts of skins i don't think has
yet joined us
apologies cancer schemes sorry i joined
about half an hour ago well
well more than that about 20 pounds
sorry i'm late yes
four thank you very much apologies for
that counselor stamp
thank you counselor swain
councillor mr thompson poor
thank you thank you very much miss bird
uh so we now move on to item number
seven uh approval to consult on the
draft list of local heritage assets
for the parishes of saint lawrence
wooden walter langford and alting
this is found on pages 75 to 116.
members are reminded that if you wish to
speak on this item
please make this known by using the chat
function within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
mr houston is now going to do a
presentation
for us uh mr howson
uh good evening chairman um i'm just get
my screen up hopefully you can see
this right um
yes i'm going to just show you a few
slides but
um i will only take five minutes of your
time
this item seeks your the committee's
approval to consult on the next phase of
the parish lists of local heritage
assets
most members will be familiar by now
with these
lists but to recap the
buildings on these lists are those which
fail to meet the strict criteria for
national listing but are nonetheless of
local value because of their
architectural and historic interests
they've been identified using our own
adopted
selection criteria which is set out on
the inside cover of each
parish list and inclusion on a local
list is a light
touch designation in that it does not
impose any additional planning
restrictions the alterations an owner
can currently make
without the need for planning permission
will remain the same following
designation but what inclusion on a
local list
does mean is that where planning
permission is required
the heritage significance of the
building will be a material
consideration
in determining the application
and as the report explains preparation
of
such list is something encouraged in
national planning
practice guidance over the past
year lists have been produced and
adopted for
10 of the parishes in the modern
district and this slide
shows the front cover of each of the
adopted parish lists which are all
currently available
on the council's website so we're
now about a third of the way to
completing the whole district
and this report concerns lists which
have been drafted for the parishes of
saint lawrence wooden walter lankford
and
ulting they've been prepared with
assistance from
various local historians and enthusiasts
who are individually
credited um preparation of the wooden
walter list has been informed
by the work of the wonderful local
historian pat ryan who sadly passed away
last month i think the three
documents for your consideration
identify and
celebrate a really interesting
collection of historic buildings 29 in
total
and i'm just going to very briefly show
you a few of the highlights in
roughly chronological order of their age
the oldest building to be identified is
st lawrence
hall this is the principal manor house
of
saint lawrence and in this photograph
you can actually see the shadows of the
medieval
timber frame structure showing through
the modern render
and a survey a couple of years ago
revealed an impressive
crosswind built around the year 1500
which originally had these amazing
windows with arched
heads and there are only around 100
medieval houses to survive
in the district which makes this quite
an important survival
several fine georgian
farm houses and farm buildings have been
identified particularly in wood and
walter
where research by pat ryan established
the date
that each of these were built um
of course these fine buildings
illustrate the prosperity of
farmers in the late georgian period in
this part of essex
the lists include three lovely victorian
schoolhouses the one at the bottom left
is in langford is designed by the county
architect
frederick chancellor who also designed
langford mill one of the most notable
and imposing
uh buildings in langford uh replacing uh
the previous mill which burnt down in
1879
and then moving into the 20th century
there are an important group
of architect designed arts and crafts
style buildings around the warren estate
in woodland walter
commissioned in the early 20th century
by henry walter thompson
who laid out the golf course
the birthing area for stone sailing club
in st lawrence
is uh based on the embarkation hard
built in 1942 and used for the normandy
landings in 1944 so a particularly
precious in-situ remnant of a decisive
event of world war ii
and then finally the youngest building
instant
it is a st lawrence water tower
which was built in 1966 uh and it's an
elegant and sculptural landmark
occupying a prominent position at the
top of
the hill and of course it's a monument
to the 20th century improvements in the
supply of water to the dengue peninsula
so in conclusion if you decide to
the committee decides to approve these
lists for public consultation
we will first of all write to every
owner
and then the parish councils and ward
members seeking
everyone's views the draft list will be
published on our website and there will
be the opportunity for members of the
public
to submit further nominations for uh
consideration
and then following the public
consultation we will
report back and seek approval from a
future meeting of this committee to
adopt the lists incorporating any
amendments
as a result of the consultation
so that's the end of my my brief
presentation
thank you mr houston so the
recommendation has set out in the report
is as follows
that the draft list of local heritage
assets for the parishes of saint
lawrence
wooden walter langford and alting are
approved for public consultation
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video and
mute your microphone
and state your now
chairman i i heard councillor helm first
of all thank you very much councillor
helm
uh i would now like to call people who
would like say the first person i have
on my list is councillor stamp
thank you chairman um i'd like to thank
mr houston yet again
even though i wasn't elected he's
produced many of these and taken them to
the district council
they're all excellent i can't
congratulate you enough on all the hard
work
it's so important that heritage is um
saved for prosperity and for the next
generations and i personally would like
to thank him again so thank you mr
harrison
excellent work thank you chairman thank
you council stamp council logan
yeah thank you thank you chair um just
to echo really counselor stamps comments
there i mean um
tim every time i see a list like this
come across
an order paper for us to look at it's an
absolute pleasure because the huge
learning that's given for us as members
and other members of the public to look
at the heritage that we've got
you know i was born in malden but i've
loved this district since i was born
and to learn about some of the buildings
and the heritage we've got we've got
a wonderful first world war and second
world war airfields and infrastructure
and buildings that
we have to protect and this extensive
work
is first class and absolutely fantastic
so i just want to echo that and have
that on record
and you have our appreciation for that
so thank you so much
thank you council logan councillor
durham
oh thank you chairman i again i would
like to thank mr house and you know this
is yet again
a sterling bit of work uh and we're
gradually working our way through the
through the villages it's it's
fascinating details i was just a little
bit shocked and sad and when
when tim told us that pat ryan had
passed away last month
um i knew pat pretty well she she you
know what would we have done
in local history without patricia ryan
um a lovely lady
um so thank you for letting me know she
is actually the mother of
one of the parish council clerks in my
warden division so
um forewarned his forearm but thank you
mr house and for an excellent
piece of work thank you and your
counselor durham councillor schemes
yeah thank you chair um yes uh fantastic
work
um just a quick question about things
still to be added to the list
as i know you're aware tim i sent some
information over about the stages in
burnham how does that get worked into
the system um because i think we did
bradwell
and burnham and those sort of things
some time ago
um do you know how it all comes back
into the system to make sure
to ensure that it does get involved
through the chair
thank you mr councillors again mr halsen
yes um burnham has not been done yet
it is in draft form i had a meeting with
uh several locals and some delegates of
burnham town council
just before lockdown so they were hoping
to help out with survey work which is
delayed things slightly but
burnham is next on my list to to
tackle okay thank you mr allison thank
you
council channel um
thank you chairman it's going to sound
like the mr house and fan club tonight
and quite rightly
yeah appreciation because uh mr houston
knows how much i value his work and i'd
just like to say thanks because saint
lawrence is in my ward of mayland
so thank you for um what you um
have put forward then i'm sure st
lawrence parish council and residents of
st
lawrence will be pleased to see um what
you're intending
also um councillor wife being in contact
and asking if i could please highlight
and thanks for your hard work
and she refers to the water tower
because that's very very important
so thank you there is a mutual
admiration society but i think the
council's very lucky
i have to say this to have an officer
such as mr helsin
whom who really is diligent in his work
and really does bring the heritage of
our wonderful district home
um to everyone through the work that he
does so thank you very much
thank you chancellor councillor thompson
sorry chairman um yes i'm afraid it's
another one
the appreciation society um but i do mr
house and has always done such wonderful
work
very passionate about this subject um
and i'd like to
thank him very much on behalf of the
whole district thank you
thank you councillor thompson i have a
quick question for for mr hassan and and
again i appreciate the work that you're
doing and and
the the fantastic reports and
information you provide for us
just out of interest uh how long is this
going to take and
and when will it all be done yeah
because it seems a mammoth job and
and i yeah and you are doing sterling
work but is there a sort of an end point
or
when you see that you will have done the
whole district
you'll be as old as me probably well
we've only been doing it for i think a
year and a half
and we've covered a third of the
district so we should we should
we'll eventually get there within not
too distant future
okay thank you very much
chairman can i just jump in there it's
funny because you know when we get the
list of
levers i always check to make sure mr
houston's not on that
because he is irreplaceable as all the
members have actually said
tonight and so many other officers i'm
not sort of just
uh singling him out but he does an
excellent and excellent job so thank you
thank you councillor stamp so uh i now
move to the vote
uh so can i take a cent for this
particular
recommendation that we
adopt the draft for approved public
consultation for those
parishes
thank you members so we now move on to
agenda item 8 north key development
brief
supplementary planning document found on
pages 117
to 204. members are reminded that
if you wish to speak on this item please
make this known by using the chat
function
within this meeting i will then come to
you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succinct mrs longman could you please
present your report
okay um so the report concerns the
responses to the six-week public
consultation
on the draft north key development brief
supplementary planning document
the north key development brief is a
requirement of the local development
scheme
and is a project from the central area
master plan
spd this background is set out in
paragraph 3.1
3.6 of the report all the responses are
summarized within appendix one the
consultation statement
and i've given an overall summary at
paragraph 4.4
in the report overall there is support
for the north key
key development brief supplementary
planning document
to regenerate the north key as in the
north key defined area
in the manner set out in paragraph 3.3
of the report
amendments that are proposed to the
brief set uh
summarized and set out in paragraphs
four point four point one to four point
four point four point
four point three sorry right um
amendments um are proposed referencing
strategic
policy guidance further design guidance
and action plans
and strategies not available at the time
of the public consultation
the prosperity strategy is referenced to
promote
the north key and to stimulate private
sector interest in the area
we've updated the developer
contributions section
um to take account of ram's
contributions and progress with
seal there was a requirement
for a sca hra screening opinion
that concluded that sca wasn't required
but the hr screening
is completed in consultation with
natural england
given the proximity of the north key to
designated habitats so the brief
provides a planning infrastructure
provision and design
guidance framework to bring development
forward
to regenerate the north key as set out
in adopted
ldp policy and the modern haybridge
sanctuary master plan spd
the brief will give greater certainty
and assistance to
developers working up playing out
planning applications
in the north key area for employment-led
regeneration schemes
the north key development brief will be
a material consideration
in the planning process thank you
thank you and thank you very much for
such a detailed
report that you provide to us and the
work that you
uh so i'd like to put forward the
recommendation and the recommendation
that the north key
development brief be adopted as a
supplementary planning document
if anybody wishes to second that emotion
please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now please
thank you councillor helm my god council
help me quick tonight
he's fast tonight
uh thank you i will now invite members
to make any comments on the report
and i have uh councillor swain
yes thank you chairman um i have two
concerns
um um in in the document
um firstly the comment
of a new generous keysight walk is a
long-term
aspiration um why is it only an
aspiration
it doesn't sound like it's um really
fully catered before
in the plan the second area concerns
park and ride parking or whatever public
parking
and how people may use either the
288 or other bus services to access
malden high street there's
no specific provision for such parking
um and it mentions only that um
whether you would look for an
opportunistic or
a redundant site it doesn't it should be
more specifically
catered for i would have thought um
lastly um
i note the the flood risk management um
document um risk assessment
i think is due
imminently i wonder if that is still the
case
thank you this is longman
hi there yeah i think there were about
three questions there
regarding the key sidewalk um in terms
of
um on the north key side
um that is an aspiration but because of
existing
land ownerships and access to private
property
and we can't achieve the same on the
north key as we
have done on the south key so we have
the river sidewalk
on the south key that then goes over
full bridge
you can go down station road
so far but we're relying on the sad's
wolf development to open up
that access to to the haybridge creek
frontage so
it's an aspiration in the sense that we
would love to have a
a northern riverside walk but we cannot
achieve that due to the current land
ownerships
okay your next question with regard to
provision
for parking um uh there are there is
existing parking at
you know at retail um uh
areas um around the north case at the
blackwater retail park tesco lidl
but specifically for just for
parking the development sites
identified are for employment-led
regeneration
not to just provide car parking but any
developments that come forward we'll
have to
pay regard to the adopted vehicle
parking standards for parking required
to support any developed redevelopment
and the third question um
[Music]
was oh the flop yes the causeway
strategic flood risk review
is um now with us in draft form
it was held up because of um covid and
county who are preparing it
having to divert resources um but
that covers the entire causeway area and
where obviously it sits
in the highest flood zone so that review
is looking at
all the um current flood risk data
bringing it all together
there's a whole section in the north key
development brief section six
flood resilience and um infrastructure
so it's all set out in there what what
that
review will achieve okay cancer swing
and yes i'd just like to come back on
this question of parking because
um all the areas that are in rivers
black water
retail or wherever um or bent holes
they're all limited hours parking
because they're intended for
the businesses that are there that's not
very useful if somebody wants to um
leave a vehicle and go up into the town
um
it's like they'd be restricted
um and i think it's perhaps not just the
causeway but
slightly wider there and then perhaps in
the context of the um developments in
haybridge and
the north language garden suburb um when
it happens
that uh a proper parking ride provision
should
be made i i think
from my from my knowledge this is uh
something that we
we have looked at and and has come to
overview and scrutiny
in the past um and the logistics of of
establishing a park and ride
there are parking spaces at test codes
which are part of the park and ride
scheme
of the the bus that goes around uh the
the town center
so people parking that area could make
use
of the free bus that does go up market
hill however
in terms of my view and my headers and
strategies and resources is
is i need we we need uh the
members of the public to use the town
center car parks for our revenue
so i think we need to encourage people
to get into the town center
thank you uh councillor
um thank you very much chairman um yeah
a good report and obviously great to see
the responses from the consultation
document
but i'm sorry chairman i'm going to
question the recommendation again that
this committee adopts this supplementary
planning document
because of course the modern and central
area master plan
um which i think was supportive of s5
was adopted by council
and this planning brief supplementary
planning document is very very important
because it is about
planning infrastructure design framework
and about regeneration and actually it
is fundamental
in regarding our strategic theme
of prosperity which of course is part of
our corporate plan and very much of the
priorities of this council
so therefore chairman as it is a policy
document which is actually
very much linked to the um local
development plan
and indeed the local development um
framework
um or whatever that's now called should
this not be
a recommendation to council for council
to adopt it as they did
with the spd's for the modern and
central area master plan
thank you council china could one of the
officers come back on that please
um yeah the the the uh recommendation
yeah that
the north key development brief be is
that the recommendation to council then
or is that
no it just says that we adopt the
supplementary
doc document that's the recommendation
yeah yeah sorry so sorry if i can pick
up
apologies um chairman that should be a
recommendation
to council i'm sorry that for the fedex
we're making sure that we follow the
correct procedure which is what's
important in terms of of running a
council
so uh if we can amend the recommendation
so that the north key development plan
be adopted
as a supply planning document and to be
recommended
to full council
uh councillor stan
thank you chairman there's no need now
that's just exactly what i wanted
because i know that committees have
delegated powers
and we need to be clear of what
delegated powers they have otherwise
there's no point in keep having
committee meetings
if everything's going to go back to full
council for recommendation but i think
council channels exactly in raising it
and
mr dodson actually um did um
explain it thank you clarified it thank
you council islam
so uh there are no more people who've
requested to speak
so can i have a cent for that
recommendation to be taken to full
council
agreed great agreed
i'm terribly sorry but i don't agree
okay
so we need to have a recorded vote
mr third thank you chairman
and members if you could just indicate
for against or abstain please
and when i call your name up please mrs
channer
um four thank you very much councillor
durham
four thank you councillor edwards for
councillor helm
[Music]
four thank you very much thank you
councilman lagan against please tara
thank you councillor four
thank you cancer skins four
thank you stamp
[Music]
mrs thompson oh and councillor miss
white
thank you very much thank you tara
so we now move to agenda item nine
promenade park
garden play scheme found on pages
205-220
members are reminded that if you wish to
speak on this item please make this name
by using the chat function within this
meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points
clear and succinct mr butcher could you
please present the report
yes thank you chairman um yes i mean uh
matt wilson's absence tonight matt
produced this report and is our coastal
countryside
manager but as part of the original um
uh part of the original proposal in
november 2018
we went to committee and sought approval
on an approach for
a new uh accessible play area in
promenade park
this was funded from section 186 monies
and
and also funded from capital investment
from the council
and as part of this agreement a public
consultation was required
after a slight covert delay this was
this public consultation was conducted
online
in the summer of 2020 all that feedback
has since been collated
uh it's been presented back to our ward
members for review
and we think we've made some some really
good improvements to the scheme
we want to make sure the site is
accessible for younger years
and for children who may have specific
access requirements
and we bring this to you today as part
of the formal sign off for us to then
commence with the procurement approach
um
which we would like to start in the
coming weeks with a view for
construction to start in the early part
of 2021
and a target completion date uh in the
late spring
early summer of 2021.
um thank you chair if there's any
questions or more than happy to answer
them
thank you mr butcher so the
recommendations are set out in the
report are as follows little one
that the revised guard and play area
design proposals attached at
dependencies
a and c be agreed little two
the officers proceed with procurement of
all elements of the play site and
associated works based upon this design
via existing supplier framework
agreement if any member wishes to second
that motion
please send on your video unmute your
microphone and state your name now
please
wait a second chairman thank you
councillor durham
uh i will now invite members to make any
comments and i have counselor durham
i should be extremely brief chairman i
think this is
excellent um you know there's a real uh
a huge amount of work gone into this and
it will be an absolute asset for not
only malden the prom park
but the district as a whole um thank you
very much indeed
thank you for that support council
durham
uh councillor yeah thank you
i do echo uh what council durham said
but i have a little bit of a couple of
questions that's okay
um does it cater for uh disabled and
special needs children
is there anything specific specifically
in there and i'm see you nodding your
head so when i stop speaking can you
explain that to
members and members of the public who
are listening
and the other question and reassurance i
would like to have
is security element you
you put uh or the district put that
beautiful um
was it high hide or something whatever
it was and it kept getting damaged what
guarantees have we got
if any that this isn't going to be
maybe damaged in the future are there
any guarantees
thank you thank you chairman um
yes thank you chair thank you councillor
stamp yes there are some
um specific elements uh going in that
are specifically for
uh children with access requirements
things like
swings which will take a wheelchair and
can be strapped in
and other safe swing and safe play for
um for children with
with those um yeah specific needs and
some learning disabilities as well
we hope that this will be the the first
part and we will look to
uh develop the surrounding area uh
further all be it enhanced
um and have a sensory area in some of
the soft planting
and those sorts of things so um
so so yeah we're trying to make it as
inclusive to all uh as possible
uh in relation to the security uh i'm
afraid i can't make any guarantees
but we are proposing as part of the
scheme that we do invest
into a new cctv column uh that will
cover the area
that cctv will be part of our chelmsford
contract so it will be
live monitoring and they will be able to
um if any incidents are occurring uh
they will be able to alert the police to
respond
uh very very quickly brilliant chairman
can i just come back and ask another
question
um mr butcher are we doing a sensory
garden
as well i mean are we doing planting
because it's not just a matter of going
on swings we can stimulate
um children uh in in other ways and
encourage them have we consulted anybody
on sensory gardens
have we got a special area that that can
be accessed to
whether it be on raised beds i don't
know i can't tell for the drawing i have
tried
uh but i think it's really important
that all members and the members of the
public know exactly what your
uh what modern are planning at this
stage thank you
yes there there will be a um uh it is
our intention to put a sensory garden in
there
uh council stamp i can only apologize
it's not my field of expertise and matt
wilson will be able to give you a lot
more detail if he's
if he wasn't unwell tonight um but i'm
happy to ping you an email with all the
follow-on details but yes it is
absolutely our intention to have a
sensory garden
different plants and trees and shrubs
for uh children to look feel smell
yeah thank you thank you chairman i
think other members would be interested
to know about that as well and maybe
an app or something to be developed in
the future i mean sometimes
they have little special ipads and
everything and it's a great learning
tool
for children who may need some extra
assistance to actually go and get very
excited when they're actually in a park
in an open space so
thank you congratulations thank you
thank you
councillor
yeah thanks chair um first of all just
um
you know commend the officers for the
approach
ward members were invited down with matt
on a very nice summer's day to go
through the whole progress
uh and process to walk through and my
initial reaction was
i was horrified they're going to rip the
maze out they're going to rip the cedar
out it's going to
it's going to be all full you know these
things have been put in and they have
been put in by
really fantastic organizations over the
years um but the modern society
who deserves some some mention of the
work that they do
however when you stop and think about it
you know
council stan mentioned about security
there's a lot of unsavory behavior that
actually goes around
in that area regrettably and this is a
young
person's uh play area that really will
bring some stimulation so
it'll actually be i think a safer area
for families especially young children
to go
with their parents or carers um having a
significantly disabled family member of
ourselves uh i commend the the
the thought that's going into the work
to bring these guys to be inclusive
which is what they should be across
absolutely every walk of life
um so really initial shock was my god
should we be spending this money then it
was explained it was ring fenced
the money was there and then the plans
which have been supported and the proof
of the pudding is in the eating because
the
consultation has given some very strong
strong feedback
for that so um i think it's a really
good thing it's going to bring a
different dynamic it's evolution within
within the
the park area and i look forward to
seeing this realised
and again what um steve has just said
along with matt
that sort of the next stages that can
bring uh the learning and inclusivity in
a safe
and comfortable environment coming
forward so i just appreciate what you've
done
thank you councillor lagan councillor
white
he missed him um just as to um thank the
officers for their work on this
i mean ever since i was chairman of
um community services which used to deal
with the prom park and the play park
i i've always been in support of it
because it is a jewel in our
crown and it is very important for the
malden district
and the malden district council to make
the prom park the best it can be and i
think this is only a good thing
so keep up the good work brilliant thank
you council white
councillor swain
yes thank you chairman um yes
i'd like to say that um i and councillor
lagan
and uh one or two other malden
councillors um have had um
an opportunity to discuss the whole
project with um
with matt wilson um for which we
are very grateful and so
we were fully uh in the picture of the
what was um
intended for the area um and i i
understand that there's overwhelming
support for
um such an activity which i i'm sure
will help to draw more people to
the promenade park and provide a wider
variety of um
enjoyable features for um well
particularly for young
for younger children um i have
so i fully uh support the the scheme
i i'm on the financial question um
as i understand it there is um it's a
combination
of um section 106 money which is
specifically for this
um kind of project in or this project um
and uh other pot of money that has been
put aside for
goodness stories two or three years i
suppose um and i
just wanted to check because i i was um
under the impression that the section
106
money was
did need to be used in the fairly near
future um
i don't have confirmation on that but
the money is obviously set aside and
dedicated to it
any council saying mr butcher yes that's
correct
uh council swaying the money um so the
section 106 money that was 52
000 pounds uh that was awarded to modern
district council 2017. we actually had
10 years
and a 10-year time frame to spend that
so
so we're well well within that and the
other 48 000 was approved by committee
um uh from modern district council from
their capital budget in 2018
uh that was then carried forward into
the next financial year and and
uh subsequently here we are now uh
looking to um allocate that money and
and
perhaps even spend all of it before the
31st of march we'd like to um
uh it might be a bit ambitious but we're
hoping for an april may
um opening of the park
yes certainly hope so thank you thank
you council swain
uh councillor channel
thank you very much chairman um yes i'm
i'm fully supportive of this and
actually uh
councillor stamps touched on something
about the century garden that's good to
hear that that
there is going to be a sensory garden
and um i would i'm sure the whole
committee and
council of stamps said other members
will be interested i think champ to be
useful for that information to come
around to the all committee members
as it was raised in it but can i just
say i appreciate there's been the public
consultation i appreciate there's some
work to do with this and going through
procurement or whatever
but to give ownership on something like
a sensory garden or
you know it's going to be um have
disabled persons
our only suggestion chairman just need
to bear in mind um
and i'll declare an interest here
because in the past i've been involved
in
um organizations that have sensory
impairment people in fact i was a member
myself as the ones
sometimes we all need support and
actually what's quite nice and i've
certainly seen it in other areas whereby
when we're doing something like this
maybe a competition amongst our sensory
impaired people disabled people or in
fact the general public
have a naming of perhaps what the
sensory garden
area might be called and i've seen that
happen before so people really find that
interesting to know something's coming
but also be involved in something
whereby they have a chance
perhaps to name that part of um
of the site as well um and that gives
then
real public um if you like
stakeholdership or ownership as well
um i'm just making a suggestion chairman
that was all really thank you counselor
china
i'm sure we can incorporate that mr
butcher yes something we'll take forward
yeah
okay thank you very much councillor
schemes
uh absolutely absolutely beautiful
scheme uh
really wonderful idea just one comment a
sort of comment that i'd like to make
quite often as time goes on
and that is great for malden which is
super superbly provided in the in the
prom park
but i do need to draw everybody's
attention
to the rest of the district and in
particular obviously since
my uh burnham south is my ward burnham
and the uh riverside park there
um it will be i just want to try and uh
as much as i can
push into officers minds and other
members minds that uh
uh the more tourism and uh
the more facilities that we can provide
across the district
uh the better and i do hope that uh a
scheme like this
or similar schemes will start appearing
in places like burnham
and some of the uh other outlying towns
and villages
i think it's really important okay i'm
sure that's something that we can bear
in mind mr butcher
yes absolutely um uh thank you chair
thank you councillor skins yes we do
have um
proposals in the um capital budget for
next financial year uh specifically for
riverside uh riverside park uh they are
service improvements um but that will be
down to councillors
uh to debate and decide um but but
should they
choose to support um a development in
burnham on crouch that's
a similar similar play area would be
absolutely delighted to uh to deliver
something like that in the area
thank you mr butcher counts let's wait
you wanted to come back could you do
that briefly please
yes very briefly um i know people i was
concerned about the um
removal of the cedar there and um
as um that wilson explained um
it is actually in danger of toppling
over it's very is unstable so
um that's why this unfortunately has to
come out
thank you council swain for that
contribution
uh so yeah i would just like to add that
i think this is a fantastic scheme
i know the resources of the council are
stretched at the moment however the
money money has been set aside as mr
butcher
has specified and also the the the
um section 106 agreement money so
yeah we are only enhancing and enabling
more people to come to
the prom park by this development and
they should be commended
so i would now like to thank you mr
butcher now i'd like to
move to the vote uh can i take that
via assent please agreed great
great agreed
thank you very much members i'm
conscious of the time
and we have only got to item number ten
so what i would like to suggest is
that we have a five minute comfort break
before we move on to the remaining items
are we in
agreed to that agreed
so it's now 7 56
so if we could start back again at 801
thank you very much that was just to
make sure that we've all got our
videos recorders set for break off so we
don't miss it after the meeting
uh so we now move to agenda item 10
update on disabled facilities grant
related issues
found on pages 221 to 224
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known by using the chat function
within this meeting i will then come to
you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succinct uh mr gayler
is attending the meeting to present this
item and we'll be showing a few slides
as part of his summary of the report
to highlight the key points mr gaylor
thank you counselor just for note
unfortunately i'm having connection
issues so i'm not going to display the
slides just in case
of anything but i will go through what's
in the report so
obviously this is uh to provide an
update in relation to the council's
disabled facilities
grant program up to quarter 2 of 2020
2021
so the key recommendations um and issues
are really that members
know a change of focus if you like from
the term disabled facilities grant
to the more all-encompassing term of
private sector housing objectives
the second recommendation is that
members note the impact obviously of
covid on service delivery
and i'll come on to that again in a
minute and the third point is just to go
through some of the stats and figures
um that we've got up to quarter two
which is
up to the 30th of october 2020.
so just a very brief update on the
process itself so obviously the disabled
facilities grant
um is a requirement under the housing
grants and construction and regeneration
act 1996.
the disabled facilities grant is
administered as part of the better care
fund so obviously we get a pot of money
and
that pays for the disabled facilities
grant works now the fund has been
increased year on year by central
government of which morden gets a
proportion
and those looking to access the funds uh
typically
apply for a grant we do a means test to
see that
what their incomes and savings are to
determine whether there's any
contributory
finances required towards the completion
of those works
now whilst officers and members will
refer to that as the disabled facilities
grant as i've mentioned it's part of a
much wider
scheme of works referred to as the
private sector housing objectives
and so you may start to hear it being
referred to in that term moving forward
in relation to the various impacts uh on
service delivery
uh for 2019 2020 and 2020 to 2021
uh obviously the biggest uh well there's
two main ones uh
the first one was the transformation
program the council went through
a major transformation program to
implement the ignite model
and that concluded around october 2019
now as with any large-scale
transformation program
there were impacts in relation to
service delivery and job roles were
redefined and staff left and joined
where we are now is that as of july 2020
we have a disabled facilities grant
caseworker
and we also have a disabled facilities
grant specialist
and their job is to basically administer
the functions of the
private sector housing objectives
primarily that is the disabled
facilities grant work
but their scope will start to increase
as things go on
in relation to the second main
contributory factor to
service delivery uh is obviously kovid
now we've had to really adapt our
services
um because of the substantial effects of
the pandemic
uh so initially um because many of our
uh customers and clients if you like are
vulnerable people
um shielding and covered secure checks
delayed many aspects of the dfg process
so assessments and technical surveys
administration of
applications all of that slowed now as
the kovid rules were relaxed
we were able to then um incrementally
resume different aspects of the work but
we geared it towards
completing all the administration and
paperwork processes
so that they were ready to go to
contractors for when that side of the
work began to open up and we were
allowed to
get contractors to go back around to
people's houses in a safe and secure way
so those were the two main impacting
factors
on the administration of the of the
better care fund
so in terms of the general work
performance
for 2019-2020
um 2019-2020 we were allocated a fund
of around 499 961
for that financial year the council
approved 36 cases
and the total expenditure for that
period uh amounts to 351 000
so the remaining balance which was 148
961 that was carried over uh for the
continued
um purpose of working on disabled
facilities grants
so in terms of where we are now for 20
uh
for 2020 2021 our budget for this year
um is 539 488
um and that's um you know if any of that
is underspent
just to confirm that will be carried
over to 2021
2022 who will not be lost um
as of quarter two the council has
received uh
74 referrals uh for defg works
and there's a further 49 cases uh in the
background
at various stages of application uh
now the current um committed expenditure
uh amounts to 79 113 pounds
and you know that seems like a very
small amount it gives you some scope
about how limited we've been
with all the restrictions during kovid
but there was
a significant number of applications in
progress
and it's estimated at the minute that we
will be in the region of a spend of
around 250 000 to 300
000 by the end of the financial year so
that's where we are at the minute and
the last comment because i know
it's a question that some people have
raised
as far as we're aware the government is
continued to the commitment to
fund these types of work through the
better care fund
um as i said we're not going to lose any
money anything that isn't spent this
year
will be carried over uh into the next
financial year specifically for that
purpose
and it's hoped that um as things start
to unlock further that we'll be able to
um speed ahead with many of the works of
many of the
applications that have been um processed
up to that certain point
um and we'll start to work um more
effectively with contractors to get
stuff done speedily
so that's where we are a minute any
questions thank you very much mr gaylor
uh we'll come up to questions in a
minute so first of all i'd like to set
out the recommendations
and the recommendations are little one
that members note the impact of the
ongoing covert 19 issues on the service
provision
little two that members receive and note
the status
up to quarter two to uh
30th of october 2020. any members wish
to second that motion please turn on
your video
and mute your microphone and state your
name now please
thank you very much councillor stamp i
will now invite members to make any of
the comments on the report and
councillor schemes
uh yes thank you very much um i just
want uh there was something that
uh damien said early on uh i think it
refers to 4.5 on page 222.
whilst many officers and members refer
to the associated works as a disabled
facilities grant
it's actually part of a wider statutory
responsible
statutory's responsibility better
referred to as a private
sector housing objective i'm
worried about that um because that
sounds like a much more generally uh
generally applicable uh
sort of way of spending the money i i do
feel we need to focus i'm sure it will
do but
uh i don't i think there are dangers in
changing the names of things
if it's a disabled facilities grant
all about helping people with
disabilities we should
we should not put it under a title even
if they may naturally sit under it
we need to keep that there's the main
focus private sector housing objectives
is
sort of very ephemeral it's sort of um
you know it doesn't seem to mean
anything whereas disabled facilities
grant is clear precise
and we know exactly what it's all about
just to go to my point thank you
what i would say is that um the disabled
visit or the better care fund which
um administers the disabled facilities
grant will always be for the purpose of
um if you like vulnerable customers uh
just to give you some of the examples of
stuff that fall within the
private sector housing remit and this is
an example that one of my other officers
has um you know advised on we've
discussed it
um so we've talked about for example
handy person services for vulnerable
people we've talked about home from
hospital proposals
uh we've talked about um aspects
of tackling full fuel poverty um
so those are the sort of things that
fall within the private sector housing
objectives
um i mean by all means it will always be
referred to as the disabled facilities
grant
you know process but it was just to make
members aware that
that's a smaller part of a bigger chain
of works
sure no uh through the chair i i i do
understand that but it just felt like we
were going
it's all going to be start um it's just
going to become too vague
uh for me if we start talking about the
private sector housing objectives
it loses touch with the people we're
aiming it at uh vulnerable people
uh maybe just different obviously to
disabled people but i just think we need
to take
care with that that's all i understand
thank you any cancer schemes
uh i don't have a request for any other
counselors to speak so thank you mr
gaylor
uh so i will now move to
the vote uh can we take that counselor
stuff are you coming back then or are
you just flashing at me
no you were just done sorry i'm just
waiting to go agree with you
and i was just preempting you i do
apologize that's all right
uh oh uh sorry counselor lagan would you
you got in there just before
yeah that worried me a little bit about
you know the terminology of it um
and it still worries me a little bit so
i'd feel a little bit you know although
i get i get the scheme i get the intent
of it i think it's an absolutely
fantastic thing to have
and maybe spend every single hay that
we've got on the people who need it and
deserve it
but um i'm just not very keen on the
title okay so
i don't know if you could put like one
disabled and vulnerable persons in there
or something like that
it's just an idea some feedback mr galer
sure
i think that's the national term that's
used unfortunately which is okay you're
absolutely right
it's not it makes it very generic um
but across what i would say is across
all organizations that that refer to it
as a private sector objectives
um the disabled solicitors grant is
always present and so are some of the
other schemes as well that i've
mentioned
okay thank you thank you very much
so i shall now move to the votes uh if
members are in agreement we can
do this via ascent can i take a cent for
this particular
recommendation that we uh note the
impact of the ongoing cavity 19 on
issues on service provision
and that members receive and note the
status up to quarter two
of the 30th october 2020. does that
agree
noted thank you thank you very much
members
thank you thank you mr scala
so you now move on to just my yeah item
number 11 which is
the documentation retention policy
update
found on pages 225 to 292
members a reminder that if you wish to
pick on this item please make this known
by using the chat function within this
meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
mr leslie has informed me that mrs
holmes is going to be presenting this
report
mrs hopes
thank you chair yes um as hopefully all
counselors will know we
uh currently have a document retention
policy um
following a recent audit and
review of all our documents um
mrs councillor thompson you have your
mic on
thank you thank you thank you chair um
so we reviewed the policy we've we've
updated it
um the previous policy referred to the
new general data protection regulations
and the data protect
protection act excuse me 2018 coming
into force
um they're obviously now in force so the
policy has been amended
to reflect that uh one of the the second
recommendation
also asks members to provide a delegated
authority
for offices for the data protection
officer and the director of resources to
amend
the appendix the retention periods at
the end of that document
those periods are based on managers
recommendations
considering how long they need to keep
documents
um and that is reviewed annually and
allowing that delegated authority means
that
officers can keep up to date with
changes
um and don't have to return to members
to do what's
an operational matter and it allows us
to keep
reviewing it making any changes that are
needed obviously if
the main policy was to change that would
still return to members um
but the the second recommendation allows
us
to have a working document that
hopefully
officers and staff can use and is a live
document without
um having to return to members on a
record
thank you mr holmes so the
recommendations are set out in the
report
as follows to the council item little
one
that the documentation with policy
attached at appendix one be approved
item little two that delegated authority
be given to the director of resources
in consultation with the data protection
officer to make any operational changes
to the retention periods contained
within the policy
any member wishes to second that motion
please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now please
kevin not a second that please uh thank
you thank you very much councillor logan
uh i will now invite uh members to
speak and i think
counselor skins is the first on my list
hello yes um i'm concerned about getting
rid of any documents that the council
hold especially in this electronic era
when it can all be reduced
down to a micro dot or the electronic
uh equivalent and be thoroughly
searchable
while i understand paper documents and i
i'm
somebody tell me if i'm we're only
talking about paper documents here but
if we're talking about electronic
records
i think the more we keep the better and
the and in a in a fully searchable
function that we should be able to get a
hold of
uh for it i can give you a perfect
example we were looking for ownership of
a particular piece of land
in burnham uh for which we had a public
project considered
and we couldn't find whether moore
district council owned it or not
uh perhaps because it goes off to some
dark archive somewhere i'm very keen on
the idea that we keep
everything electronically that we that
we produce
and that it's really uh intelligently
searchable
and that we don't get rid of anything
except the paper which of course can be
recycled
let's come back yes thank you chair um
unfortunately the data protection act in
relation to personal data requires us to
get
to destroy data when it's no longer
required that's a legal requirement
that relates to personal data so unless
we have a justifiable reason for
retaining that
we have to have an end date now some
documentation
statute requires us to keep it
permanently which we do
and there may be some documents um
certainly in terms of of land ownership
um those sort of documents we would keep
while
for the period that we own the land um
but unfortunately
we would be in breach of the data
protection act if we didn't have a
policy
and if we kept all documents uh
forever um because i think the
information commissioner would quite
quite rightly say why do you need to
keep a request for somebody's bin to
have been
failed to have been collected that goes
back 20 years there's no need for us to
keep that information so
the idea of the policy is that we only
keep those documents
that the council need to function so
that's
planning documents statutory documents
but
we have them policies in place to get
rid of the documents in terms of the
the day-to-day queries the the short
pieces of work that officers deal with
on a day-to-day basis where
once we've completed a job there's no
requirement for us
there's no legal need for us to keep
that document documentation
so unless we can justify for every type
of document why we would need to keep it
forever
what future use it would have we need to
have a document
retention policy but if you look through
some of the documents that we have
do have a permanent uh time frame on
them so they are kept permanently
um where there is a legal requirement to
do that or whether there is an ongoing
need okay let's just quickly come back
uh council schemes completely accept
that of course everything under
data protection uh rules must we must
accord with that
but i am concerned that uh information
that
could prove useful 10 15 20 years from
now
does go missing uh and it would be
wonderful to
have some guidance on how uh
on just on on well either a system in
which uh there
there's a redaction process so you
finish with something you go through you
take out all the personal details
but you have the main facts still there
or you have
or some uh
but it just seems to me that we are in
danger of losing
what it is at the end of the day a
record and a history of the district
uh and i am hoping that we are on the
side of
um keeping as much as we possibly can in
a searchable format
uh rather than uh saying oh well the law
doesn't require us to keep this so we
won't
that's that was the phrase that i was
worried about uh
in in your statement emma thank you
thank you council skins
sorry where is it possible to come come
back in terms of
in terms of historical documents there
is scope
um for officers if they feel documents
have historical significance
that they can be referred to the essex
records office um so
if there are documents that are found
that that are old that have some
implication on the history of the
district
they can be passed on and retained uh
for future use
um so that they're not lost okay
good thank you cancer skins uh counselor
stan
thank you chairman i think emma holmes
has answered the point
what i wrote down as i agree with it as
long as it's legal and lawful
but i note that emma's referred to at
the essex records office i
totally understand what council skeins
is saying uh we have had
um disputes about ownership because the
records haven't been kept
and i totally share his concerns and i'm
sure that molden district council when
they
do their is it how many documents i
can't remember it was on the previous
committee meeting that they're going to
all put
um on microfiche or whatever you call
it's going to scan it's going to cost
this council a lot of money
i i hope they do take um cancer schemes
comments into consideration
because it's very true historical
documents do get lost
and it causes parish and town councils
a massive headache when there is land
ownership and disputes about whatever
who owns what so i think that's a very
good point well made cancer schemes and
hopefully
emma holmes and the district council
will take on board those comments thank
you chairman
thank you council stan councillor china
um thank you chairman um and i've take
i've heard what council scheme said i'm
very interested in that
um chairman i do have a slight problem
with the recommendation
and i understand about the delegation i
have heard what emma holmes have said
however um bearing in mind the mcleod
junk judgment and how that's affected
certain things and there could be other
things coming through
through the legislative nature or
regulation changes
etc because i recognize some of these
are the requirements that might be
through legislation
and regulations i'd be happier if it
said that we had to report back to the
committee
or council let's say annually just
giving us any changes that may have
occurred by officers um regarding the
operation of this i think
that might actually help some issues
that counts for schemes raised so
um and i'd be interested though because
i see the safeguarding one about 100
years
you know safeguarding is a very
important matter also in terms of stuff
it may assist us because we're data
controllers and
we might take a lead from some other
things that might come through if there
are changes
that we might need to be aware of so i
think it might be helpful to have
feedback to the committee six six
monthly or yani probably annuals
realistic and that's the issue i do have
with the recommendation i'd want it
subject to
um notification or report back chairman
to the committee or council
about any changes um in in this uh
policy retention document that may have
been done under operational issues under
den
thank you council channel just i think
we've got it before you froze
uh miss times would any changes in teams
if there was a legal change would that
come back to committee anyway
if there was to the policy yes they
would um what we're proposing
is not in relation to the actual
retention periods um
to give some background the council has
information asset owners which
are various managers that are
responsible for the the data that they
are
that comes under them and they part of
the policies they will keep records
of data that is destroyed and when it is
so
uh it certainly could be something that
could be bought before committee on an
annual basis details of documents
if if the committee made that decision
okay thank you very much
uh councillor durham
yeah thank you very much chairman
chairman councillor stampers largely
covered what i was going to say but
i do recall having discussions two or
three years ago
may even be longer um about the massive
amounts
of paper that paper records that the
council was holding
and uh the program that we had for
scanning and archiving it electronically
and it was gonna cost
tens of thousands of pounds in fact i
think it was a considerably
more than that and there was concern
raised at the time
uh about uh some of the old planning
documents and
and other councillors are quite right in
that it's it's a very frequent thing
where we need to go back
um and and check certain aspects of
planning
but there are some very very um
nice documents uh amongst the the ones
that we hold may not necessarily be
historic but are notable locally
of interest locally and i don't know
what i i don't recall what we resolved
last time
about certain items old deeds and and
things like that it would be a great
shame to destroy
uh paper documents willy-nilly without
going through them they may not weren't
going to the records office but
um i think we should look to be keeping
some that
that may may be of interest um
to uh to the wider public thank you
okay thank you council durham uh
uh apparently we do keep items forever
if it's required by the mould by modern
district council so we will not be
deleting documents willingly is the
information that
i've been provided with and anything
that's necessary will be
will be kept and stored uh councillor
thompson
sorry thank you no my question's already
been answered okay
thank you thank you cancer swain
thank you chairman yes i was involved in
this sort of exercise
in a previous um council small-scale
stuff and in paper
uh largely and um i i noted how
ready people were to throw stuff out
um and i managed to restrain and retain
that um information which was of value
for the um the background
and history of the parish but i think
there are two reasons for taking a very
precautionary approach
one is that um there'll be documents and
workings and so on relating to um
past issues and you never know when they
may come in
become relevant again and save you a lot
of extra time
in um fleshing out some issues
um the other is that uh quite a lot and
i think
councillor darren was just alluded to
them quite a lot of the
old documents may represent
um a lot of the history
and one of the main sources of um
history for the district
and i think it needs a a practiced eye
really to sort through stuff of that
nature
before throwing it out um i accept
what's been said about personal data
and what we don't have what we do have
to what we don't
um um have to retain for legal purposes
but i think it's more the
um anything that might be useful for
future planning policy making and
anything of
that is of a vaguely social history
nature um should be retained
okay thank you council swain mrs holmes
any comments at all
as i said it is down to individual
offices um
most planning documents there is a
requirement for us to keep them
permanently anyway
um so they they are being retained in
terms of the history of
of sites um uh similarly with with
minutes
um and other important documents um most
of the documents that that
are removed are the day-to-day business
and
those are the ones that are done more
routinely certainly with
with anything that's that's old and
certainly when i'm looking through
deeds and old documents some of them are
beautiful
in terms they're handwritten and scribed
so that wouldn't be something
that that i would as an officer would
would put in the shredder
because they are beautiful documents um
it is down to individual managers and as
the data protection officer
um i certainly am often asked in terms
of
removing or destroying documents and
certainly one of those questions is
always well has
is it historical has it got any
historical significance
i can't say that i'm aware of any
historical what i would consider
historical documents or offices do
have have even been considered for
destruction most of the documents we're
talking about are
day-to-day business people's emails and
those sort of things
and old files where the mat has been
dealt with
if the person approached us again we
would be starting afresh
and the previous information wouldn't be
relevant to that situation
but i appreciate members concerns
certainly information
asset owners and officers get some
training
throughout the year in terms of data
protection and it certainly can be
something we can
highlight in the next round of training
the historical significance
so that if officers do think a document
is a historical nature
they need to raise that and we will find
an appropriate place to store it
or pass it on to the records office and
we can certainly look to
enforce that message going forward okay
thank you
yes i recall that um in fact um
places like the land registry are
becoming less and less
useful if you do need to go back and
reference
um ownership in the past or um
identifying
um deeds and and areas and property
so it could be valuable it could become
a unique resource some of this
information
thank you council thank you stamp is it
something new that you want to come back
on um
no okay is there anything that is going
to add to this debate
well yes there is actually chairman
thank you for cancer durham for
highlighting the historic
historical documents and for emma holmes
to actually put my mind at rest because
in my course of being a town councillor
i've come across some really old
documents
and it would be such a shame if they
were going to be shredded so i think
this debate
has been fantastic chairman and as long
as it is carried through to the next
level
that emma has said there's going to be
training for officers
because not everybody may appreciate the
historical value of something
when i was 19 i never wanted to live in
an old property or a georgian house
now i think they're fantastic and we
have to take that into consideration
chairman
so thank you so no but yes
noted uh counselor
shana you wanted to come back again is
this about your recommendation
that's my about my proposal chairman um
yes
i'd like to just amend that little too i
agree with it but say
subject to an annual report back to the
committee
about any change um any changes in the
retention
using that worded under delegated powers
okay and the purpose of that is
well just so we know chairman that's
well i thought i
made the point maybe i wasn't clear i
think it would be useful to know
because we're giving delegated powers as
i understand it
that's what that little two is seeking
to officers to deal with the retention
period
operationally i'm thinking that we have
a report come back on that
mr leslie
yes thank you chairman just thought it
was worth clarifying uh for the purposes
of the debate
uh the intention of the delegation uh
obviously
we're looking at more of the operational
uh matters around that for example if
we're referring to a different paragraph
in the
in the act if there was a change around
that and it was really to avoid
um perhaps more operational changes
coming back to the committee
appreciating
the opportunity committee time can be
quite valuable
and therefore the benefits potentially
of coming back with quite
uh operational changes into that i
appreciate
uh that there is an element of
discretion delegation
offered with that and it's obviously
needs for members to be comfortable
with that uh being given to officers but
that really was the intention
around that delegation so we could
really have more focused
uh reports but i think members you
need to be happy with that delegation to
take place and obviously there's other
things we do if there is a change
significantly in gdpr or members need to
be made aware of
we will have other uh avenues
to make that available so that's really
where the
mission was stemming from but of course
it's for members to be comfortable to
make the decision around that
okay thank you mr leslie council channel
is that you put your mind at ease at all
um well chairman i'm not seeking a
lengthy report i was just seeking
say bullet points saying this was
changed this was something because it
doesn't refer to the detention
you know and that was this the issue and
i understand for operational but i think
in a way that is quite helpful because
i'm bearing in mind the mcleod
legislation and other things
so that's my proposal chairman it might
not be seconded but i'll make
okay do we have a second of four
councillor channels
amendment two little two that
i'm happy to second it okay thank you
cancer schemes
quick point very quick point please uh i
am still concerned about the process
obviously i trust the officers but
people's views of
what is important is uh vary
and i'm just expressing my concern that
i'm worried
because of past experience that stuff
disappears we're going to need
20 years down the line it is one of
those things and and i don't think we
can ever
cover absolutely every eventuality but
hopefully that the officers are trained
in the right way
and so therefore that should yeah
hopefully
cover our concerns so uh
with the amendment to uh a little too
which is that a yearly report comes back
to committee
in terms of any changes to that policy
can i take a cent for both those
recommendations
agreed agree yes agree
thank you very much members
we now move on to agenda item 12
appointments to representatives on
liaison committees panels
issues found on pages 293-294
members a reminder that if we speak on
this item please make this known by
using the chat function within this
meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
mr dobson could you please present the
report
yes thank you chairman um yes there are
a number of
um working groups and outside bodies
that report directly into the
um the um strategy and resources
committee
uh these are set out in 3.1 of the
report
and members are required to to appoint
um representatives from the committee
for the
remainder of the municipal year thank
you
thank you very much so the
recommendations that the committee
points representatives to the bodies
detailed in the report for the ensuring
municipal year
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
and mute your microphone and state your
name now please
second councillor swain thank you
councillor swain
uh so i have as anybody
have any comments on this particular
no so uh oh yes councillor channel
um well yes chairman could i just make
an inquiry please before we go to the
appointments
the malden market one which i was
appointed to along with thompson's and
white
i could never recall chairman having
been summoned to a meeting of this
um has it met no idea myself
does any officer know that answer to
that question
uh sorry chairman this is yes no i never
was either and i'm not
what it hasn't met okay chairman uh
if i can help i was on it a few years
ago but it's not met
in the last three years to my knowledge
okay
mr dobson do you know whether it's met
um i don't remember
the last year chairman but if i could
make a point i think there are a number
of task and finish groups
um on this list
and they still exist but by their nature
task and finish groups should be time
limited
um i think in the first instance we
should maybe or council should maybe a
point to these
yeah but then they should meet to review
their terms of reference and whether
they're required anymore and then they
can make recommendations to the
committee
whether they continue after that thank
you mr dodson
so uh we'll take each of the groups
in turn and so we start with the waste
management
group and from the chair i
will nominate uh richard siddall cancer
ciddel
and councillor lagan and then i would
ask for two conservatives
nominations please
um well chairman if you'll permit me
then
um i take it you want the membership um
coming from this committee do you or are
these across the country
right in that case then i would propose
councillor white because she was
i think on it previously um from what
the report says
and then uh councillor um thompson or
durham really whoever would like to do
it
kevin i'm i i'm happy to do it because i
was on the original waste working group
that
awarded this contract so i do know i've
got
a lot of background on it expertise uh
can i have that seconded please
seconded so white and darren
all right so councillor siddall council
lagan councillor white
and councillor don we come on to
the next working group which is the car
parking task unfinished working group
sorry sorry i just want to clarify are
you going to do the proposals and then
vote on them all at the end or are you
voting on each one
we'll vote at the end on all i think
lovely sorry i just wanted to clarify
thank you that's okay
uh so car park task and finish working
group say from the chair councillor
siddal
and councillor swain and then i would
ask for two conservative nominations
can i propose please counselor thompson
and white
okay so we have councillor siddall
councillor swain
councillor thompson and councillor white
can i have a seconder for that please
seconded thank you
thank you uh molded market member task
and finish working group
so from the chair i nominate councillor
swain
and council edwards and i would ask for
two conservative nominations
again chairman can i propose uh thompson
and white please councillors thompson
and white
okay so to confirm that we have
councillor swain
councillor edwards councillor thompson
and councillor white can i have a second
to please second aid
thank you council thompson councillor
stamp uh
so places for people liaison committee
so from the chair
i nominate councillor swain could i have
a conservative nomination please
i'll nominate um counts well
councillor durham because he was on
their last time on places to people i
think so go with that
so yeah i'm okay with that thank you
thank you council durham
so just to confirm from the chair uh
place people layers on committee
uh i nominate councillor swain and
councillor can i have a
second for that please seconded
thank you council channel uh we then
come on to the asset coast recreational
avoidance and mitigation strategy member
forum
and from the chair i nominate kevin uh
councillor lagan
i can have a second and thank you thank
you council stamp
and then finally we come to the river
crouch coastal community
team uh management uh this
is normally the chairman and vice
chairman
from strategy and resources and the
chairman and vice chairman for pga so
obviously pj will make their own
nominations
and from the chair i will nominate
councillor siddal and councillor schemes
can i have a seconder for that please
well second there
thank you councillor skins council
channel
um thank you chairman just to say i did
send an email last night i did attend
the river crouch cct meeting today but i
did explain
the situation and said i was pretty sure
i wouldn't be around anymore
and um i think obviously they'll get
notified in due course because it used
to be the chairman and vice chairman of
the committees actually
um both the main ones community services
and p l
as the order paper depicts yeah and it
has changed to snr and pgna
um i like has been confirmed that it
does not have to be the vice chairman
that is nominated to that uh particular
forum
so we now have those uh nominations can
i
take those uh virus sent
agreed
agreed thank you very much members
so that is those positions are now
agreed
and therefore i move on to item
13
which is items of business that the
chairman of the committee decides are
urgent i have none
so we now move on to item 14 exclusion
of the public and press
so i move that the committee resolves
that under section 104 of the local
government act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business on the grounds that they
involve
the like disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph
1 of part 1 of schedule 12
a to the act and that this satisfies the
public
interest test is that uh agreed
you agreed great agreed
so tara could you please inform us when
we are no longer alive
you